[Music]
hold on before we pivot I think we need
to just lean into that for a second
Christina Cho is one of the great
directors working in the world and I'm
very very proud right now that she's
here moderating this Q&A so thank you a
well I'm honored to do this also and
just we had such a close working
relationship
I'm very lucky that I got to learn from
her I would not no but I would not be
here today if I hadn't had that
experience as I did from you you know I
think um every part of the collaboration
you know especially in editors that's a
huge you know you're also a filmmaker in
my mind so and then you became you know
you made two other film two other films
before is it like kind of it must be
like I don't know like being a mom and
I'm like the kid and you're like yeah
yes you're an adult I see you as an
adult but you're still kind of my kid no
no um but no I'm equally honored and
proud to moderate and talk about your
film and super uh exciting and want to
congratulate you on making this film
particularly you know as I said like
it's a miracle to make any film but
especially during war time is must be a
challenge that I can't really imagine
what you went through and want to talk
about the process um but also just you
know it's such a beautifully done
powerful film that really gets into you
know both the horror and the beauty of
trying to make art um during the time of
War um so why don't we get into the
beginning of the origin story of how did
you decide to make this film why did you
decide to make this
film um sure which one first how or
why um how I mean why let's start with
why
okay um are there any ukrainians here
all right slav
Ukraine all
right so
um I don't where do I start I think uh
so
I
uh my family is from the former Soviet
Union as you
know and uh they came here before uh the
Soviet Union fell
so they came I think with a lot of
really
confused uh
fractured uh
relationship to their Origins you know
two days before the start of the
fullscale war Putin uh gave a speech uh
on Russian television State television
laying out his justification for the war
saying that Ukraine doesn't exist the
culture doesn't exist the history
doesn't exist that it's one spiritual
space there's a funny his Ukrainian
historian who says who said uh if we're
all one are we Russians are we all
Russians or are we all ukrainians which
which which does Putin
mean um so imagine what the Soviet Union
told uh the the republics like Ukraine
uh about who they are and what they are
uh so I think you know this this even
this question of language how so I
inherited this
very
Soviet Ukrainian understanding of my own
identity from my
parents um and when this war started I
think it awoke in so many ukrainians
globally it's like if if ukrainians all
over the world were like this kind of
quiet hornet nest when this war broke
out this fullscale war it's like this
hornets nest was shaken and you know all
these ukrainians all over the world
they're like no wait no I'm here I am
not who he says we are um
and
uh and yeah I was I think one of those
uh people and I think I was
really like most people
inspired you know all the experts said
that Ukraine was supposed to fall in
three
days intelligence communities media this
was all pretty conventional wisdom that
it was just going to end in 3 days ke
would fall that zinsky would flee and
neither of those things
happened um two days into the
War uh
the about a mile or two miles from where
zalinsky was hiding with his wife he
could hear uh the missile fire there
were sabator circling all over key of
looking for him to kill him and Russian
misinformation had uh circulated that he
had fled
and so he uh he's a former
actor and comedian and uh his First Act
of uh Defiance was to make a film he
went outside in Kiev specifically so
that everyone could see that he's in
Kiev and he turned the camera on himself
selfie
video uh film a shot single shot one
shot heard around the world uh and he
pointed at himself and his C few key
cabinet members he
said I'm
here and uh that short film inspired me
I watched that film like a lot of people
and it sent chills down my spine and uh
I had a cinematographer who I
collaborated with before and she called
me she was like so what are we going to
do so can I ask how many days or weeks
after after the very beginning of the
war did this happen did this like call
to action in you uh activate this was a
couple of weeks a week week or two into
it oh okay yeah so you called DP she she
called me I was already kind of thinking
about what am I going to do and then
because I didn't think you know my DP is
uh
from uh is uh from Thailand so she I was
like I didn't didn't think I was going
to take her with me to Ukraine uh but
she called me she's like let's go what
are we going to do we got to go we got
to make
something um and
uh but and had you been to Ukraine
before or was but her visa situation
wasn't going to work so that's why but
yeah gotcha um but had you been to UK
you've never been to Ukraine before no I
had not I had not okay um
so so then the How uh
I reached out to a cinematographer who I
admired a Ukrainian cinematographer who
shot a movie called uh Myan uh by Sergey
lasn from 2014 uh that's a very
controversial figure right now but in
Ukraine but uh the DP Stefan I found his
number on Signal I think it was on his
IMDb Pro and I texted him and I said hey
are you are you safe I'm a fan of yours
I'm coming to Ukraine I wait really okay
so you just texted him out of the blue
and said I'm coming to Ukraine yeah okay
and then um we thought about whether we
should like get on the same page about
what we're going to talk about and we
decided we're not going to do that and
we're just going to have this
conversation no I think we should have
yeah like this is a conversation I I'm
finding out a lot of this at the same
time so I'm curious so uh so yeah um he
wrote me back he said I'm safe uh yeah
let's talk so we started talking every
night um wow he we'd be on the phone
together at night and he'd smuggle
himself a little bit of vodka because at
the time he couldn't get any and he said
I'm out on my balcony drink can you hear
that and picked the phone up he said
those are the sirens wow um and um and
then he connected me with a fixer who
was also a producer of a film that I had
loved and admired called a Ukrainian
film called stop
which one Crystal bear Berlin in
2021 he said this is my producing
partner but she's also fixer she'd been
a fixer for the Washington Post and
Associated Press and Wall Street Journal
so she was on the front line taking them
uh to the front lines
journalists um so I I called her I call
well actually he said she she'll look at
some of your work and if if she approves
then she'll get on the phone with
you um so and then how soon after that
did you actually like and could you just
fly in how did you get in so so we
started talking OA and I this producer
and uh we started talking uh every day
and there were as this was very early
days of the war so there were things you
had to bring with you you had to bring a
flack jacket um level four body armor
you had to bring a what's a level four
body armor for those of us so level
three is like if you get shot with a
handgun uh that could uh stop it level
four is like more like War like machine
gunfire wow okay um so uh so she was you
know telling me the things I need to
bring and so it took me some time to get
to try and arrange to get those things I
don't know how much you want me to tell
you about that but
um turns
out you can't bring level four body
armor on a on a Comm commercial flight
out of the US um it's considered a
military object so I couldn't get one
here uh so I found a I found a website
where I had it delivered to uh
Warsaw and I just so happened we just
talked about this I just so happened to
have a Polish Nanny from when I was a
kid who I have kept in touch with she
was like a second mom um Hana who lived
not far from Poland so I got on a oneway
flight to Warsaw uh thinking I was going
to make a film about refugees cuz my
parents were refugees my family my
parents and my sister were refugees
Ukrainian refugees of a prior uh Refugee
generation and uh so that's where my
first thought went that I was going to
make a film about ukrainians who left
like my family uh so going to Warsaw
made sense I could get my I could have
the Flack jacket sent to hanana place
and uh and interview refugees while I'm
there trying and find a story uh so I
went to
warsa and started interviewing refugees
and
uh I read an article in the Washington
Post on April 17th about lyanna and the
center and about her partner
ston
and I thought I I thought that was
something that I started looking at
different things that lyanna had said on
the internet and there was something she
had said that caught my attention I
found her on
telegram I reached out to her I got on
the phone with
her and that
night told my producer I'm like we have
something here and she was like yeah
this this resonates with me as well and
uh she put me on a bus so my fixer Oiler
who produced uh stop Simla became my
producer uh and she put me on a bus and
put vaa the DP on a train from Kiev to
laiv and the next morning I was in
Ukraine where wow okay so what month is
this was April April 2022 so how much
how much time has passed since the the
very first day of the war I was uh two
it was
just a little under two months after the
start of the F skill War well one thing
that you know I felt was very striking
like as soon as I watched the film was
like this sort of weird Eerie feeling of
like normalized life during Warfare and
sort of had all these questions like
like at what point in the war is this
that you're filming like how how much
danger are they are your main characters
in while you're filming and they're kind
of going about their business and
um you know that that was really
striking to me in the beginning and how
much you know danger were you in as far
as going in at that point yeah uh I left
out the punchline which is that the FL
jacket never came uh so um but uh blame
Amazon maybe but um
yeah so it uh well you
know it was very early days but the
state of the war was different in
different cities um but one thing that
was
uh that was uniformed throughout Ukraine
was this very complicated relationship
to the
sirens because when there's a missile
flying in the sky in Ukraine and they're
and they they can see that there's
something in the air they don't know
exactly where it's going to land which
city which town so all of Ukraine gets
the these alarms so you never know just
because there's an alarm going off
doesn't mean you're
necessarily uh going to get hit but you
might
so from very early
on you know I was in a I was in a
shelter within the first hour of my of
my getting there uh but not everybody
went you know with within two months
people are developing a the relationship
to the sirens is evolving for some
people it's like fuck it I'm not going
to get up and go I'm not going to hide
for these you
know and
uh some people are running in the street
to to hide some people aren't moving we
were in a bar and the alarm went off
some people were like I'm not going
anywhere I'm staying here and I'm
drinking my beer um some people
left
so uh you know the day that I got to to
laiv which was a relatively considered a
relatively safer City because it's in
the west
um the morning before the railway center
was bombed and an entire shop was bombed
H and seven people died
um recently it's been getting more
frequently attack uh hit by
drones but you know the front
lines were on the E were in the East and
so and how long you know did you have a
plan of like how long you're going to
stay
or you how long did you end up staying I
didn't
um I knew I needed to get home
relatively soon um my daughter was born
two weeks after I got back from
Ukraine um so I I had a I had a
deadline
um but um I was all all in all I was I
was there for a
month and how um curious like as far as
a little bit logistically like how did
you continue directing this film from
New York um you know and how did you how
much of the story did you kind of know
or plan for um and characters that you
knew you wanted to follow well the
directing stopped when I
left um to be honest with you I didn't
know what I had or if I had anything at
all you know and I think maybe this is
something you can identify with as a
director like
when you are any any filmmakers in here
in the
room yeah hi um you know when you shoot
when you're done with a shoot you have a
little bit of
PTSD you know shoot is a little bit
traumatic and you know you you get back
to you know life and you're like now I
got to look at the footage and I am
dreading looking at this because what if
can I ask you is is is most of the
footage then that in the film from when
you were there or did you did you do any
oh okay so it's like so it's like that
PTSD
times a lot you know because it's like
okay there was coming home and dealing
with having been in Ukraine but then
also the thought of not having a film
not knowing what you have I couldn't
look at the footage I didn't watch it
for three months yeah um cuz it would
just we all rised Our Lives to make this
film and the thought of not having a
film was just too much to bear and I
tried to find an editor I tried to find
a Ukrainian um I couldn't find Ukrainian
editor and then eventually was like all
right maybe if they know Russian maybe
maybe we can but you ended up I ended up
editing it myself because I couldn't
find someone to do it but I avoided it
like the plague I really tried to try
tried to Outsource it and um and then
yeah so then once I started uh editing
the three months after I got back then I
I also had a had a daughter uh and so I
had to sort of put my energy there and
and how much of like this sort the the
main Crux of the film to me which is
really exploring like what is the role
of the artist or of art during what do
you mean War like how much of I mean did
you have like some basic thesis like
going into making the fil like okay this
is what I want it to be generally about
yeah I mean I think
uh I knew I was interested in artists
but I was also interested in the role of
specifically in the role of culture in
this
war and this goes back to your first
question about
why and you know there's this historian
that I've been slightly obsessed with in
stalking a little bit um he's a Yale
Professor his name is Tim Snider anybody
know Tim Snider yeah there we
go um so um he said something to the
effect of
uh if Ukraine resisted on February 24th
2022 um then it must have existed before
then so why has it been so hard for us
to see that see that existence and that
selfhood and that nationality and that
identity and and that became something
that even I wasn't if I wasn't conscious
of it at the time something I was very
preoccupied with this this culture
question this identity question so for
me I came there uh exploring wanting to
understand and get a little closer to my
my own Roots uh and Heritage um
something that
was a bit uh distorted uh within my
family um because they had come from a
from an Imperial uh Colonial setting
that you know was constructed in such a
way that uh these cultural identities
were erased and repressed to maintain
the glue of
Empire I mean yeah it's the far the fact
that you didn't grow up speaking the
language that was really um interesting
and
and I'm curious as to at what point did
you decide that your background your
story is part of the overall fabric of
the film that was honestly that was the
very last thing to happen so so yeah and
again I don't know I mean you know how
it is when you're making films like
these decisions they're not always so um
rational they're not always so like oh
yes I'm going to do this because this
this this espec especially with Doc you
follow your nose you're kind of in the
moment you're sort of chasing at the
heels of time and chasing a story in way
like a journalist um and uh but I think
my nose went that
way towards you know the artists and
this culture question and this
information and cultural Frontline of
this war because it is a Frontline Putin
exploits misunderstandings about culture
about Ukrainian culture and identity as
very explicitly to justify war and
genocide um and
so and and
so why the artist because this helped
clarify for
me where I come from in a way that I
could identify
because you know I spent most of my most
of my life trying to make
art and films so uh when I included
myself in the story yeah that was
something I really didn't want to
do um and
uh I knew from the very beginning that I
wanted the artists making the film
filmmakers uh the cinematographer the
sound person the assistant editor uh the
producer I knew from the very beginning
that they were part of The Ensemble of
artists but I didn't think I was going
to be that's what is kind of ironic cuz
I I thought that was a really um
beautiful thing to include your
collaborators behind the normally behind
the scenes people and that they are on
the front lines of this war and their
experience is part of the story and like
you know it feels like the role of the
artists is a part of it is resistance
just to exist or just to you know have I
mean I was really kind of amazed that
they were it seems so like they didn't
skip a beat and they're just continuing
to make their art which you know I I
just remember the beginning pandemic
like all of us who that were creating
things like I was like what's what are
we doing what's what are we doing you
know and it it felt like um I don't know
maybe we just didn't see that part of
um them questioning it but it seemed
like they had this like kind of driven
purpose of like we have to keep going we
have to keep
existing well yeah I mean I think
uh
um we've made been on a lot of film sets
and there are other filmmakers in here
who've been on a lot of film sets I've
never been on a film set
that with a crew
where you know they were working in a
country that was under attack with a
cinnamon you know the first thing I did
when I got there uh Misha and vulva
picked me up we went and we had a drink
ah had a drink coffee we had coffee it
was
daytime um and uh you know he told me it
just been in bcha and you heard his
story and that Misha had just um
had to evacuate his family and all this
like I I just I've never worked with
people on a film that were going through
that and this was a film about artists
so it just kind of immediately was like
yeah yeah yeah this is your story too so
um but I
uh I showed the cut to one of my
producers at one point and she was like
David
this is this is fucked up sorry for
cursing um she's like this everybody
every all the all the artists in the
film all the film people involved in the
film are saying telling their story but
you're not the director isn't that's
weird people are going to have questions
you
know so I I feel like that's I don't
know in my experience like you need
someone outside of yeah yourself to tell
you like yeah you are part of the story
yeah and we want to yeah you are part of
I mean it's not just your collaborators
it's like you I was like no Stacy no
don't make me do
it um yeah and one thing that I wanted
to also get into is so you know we both
went to film school together and sort of
studied narrative fiction film making
and and made those films um you're
really good at this she not really good
at this streamlining me cuz I could just
go I'm a great I'm if you've noticed I'm
very good like at digressing and just
going off on some oh look at the river
in the light and you're just like let's
David David come on let's so uh what was
I saying oh okay so see I did it we
started making
films under like narrative fiction genre
right and um what I guess like
were you daunted by the idea of making a
documentary did you study other
documentaries how did you kind of dive
in and sort of you know because they are
very different uh proc the process is so
different yeah honestly I mean yeah
that's a good
question I didn't really think of them
as different and I didn't really treat
them as different
um I think that
there are more similarities between the
two than there are
differences um you know a movie is a
movie um I think the binary between Doc
and narrative is is maybe a bit too uh
strict
and yeah I mean I think you can see that
in the film making which I you know
appreciated like it almost felt like you
know in documentary you have the
traditional b-roll which um you know is
I don't know what does b-roll stand for
like it's you know BL blah blah I don't
know but it's the footage like you know
behind role behind the scenes I don't
know of the landscape or the city you
know it's and I felt like the way you
treated your you know b-roll was almost
like an art installation of like you
know there was some of the footage
outside the train felt like very tarov
skyish with like the the you know the
fog or like the the b-roll in the subway
felt very like you know it's like a
surreal dream and there was there was I
did feel sort of this influence of um
narrative film making um in a way well I
guess the way that I would put it which
maybe isn't as eloquent as the way the
other filmmaker I'm going to quote uh
put it but I think for me neither doc or
narrative has a monopoly on truth and
it's the truth is probably somewhere in
between um and there's this great I was
just in Rome and
uh I I brain fart um Dad brain Jonathan
Glazer uh was talking about his new film
and uh he said something that is going
to sound like really
I mean he's very English and he's very
intelligent but he's he's a total Punk
um in the best way um and he said that a
film is
invisible it's just it's a
feeling and the shots the images in a
film are there to achieve that feeling
right or the story you can think of the
story the same way it's not the story
for the sake of the story the story is
there to get you to a certain
feeling this idea of the film as being
this something invisible I don't know I
I I love that idea
um because of what is it feeling it
doesn't have a physical
form and that it's all in service of
that and I think whether you're making a
documentary or a narrative both are in
service of that of a of of a feeling of
a truth and Nei and those things don't
have a physical material form so
um um yeah whether it's a dock or a
narrative I think
we when we when we make those things
when we go to those things we want
similar things I don't know but maybe I
shouldn't speak for everyone
because people want different things
from different things and that's okay
too well I I think that's a good note to
end on since we are supposed to wrap up
but this idea of what you know truth
should have boundaries or
parameters right uh yeah is there any
any uh questions from the audience yeah
okay how are you changed how am I
changed
um you know the I've recently when I've
been well really since the beginning of
this I had a lot of answers for that
question but I wonder if I was telling
the
truth uh I think the trer answer is that
I'm probably still processing
that
um I want to say that it's you know
makes me
more
uh I
don't let's exchange info on talk in a
year okay is that okay
yourself the final scene with with the
girl taking her bike across the uh
across the train track how did
you come upon that and decide that that
was going to be the the end of your film
and what does it mean to you it was one
of the last decisions thanks for asking
that yeah and thank you for your
question as well
um you know it's just when you when
you're in the edit
and I spent too much time in the edit in
my life it's probably the thing I've
done more than anything which is sad
because you spend most of it alone um
but
uh you know sometimes you just kind of
perk up
and and I I think after the fact that
the the rationalization comes in um
which is that maybe the image contains a
contradiction and an ambivalence um
there's both
it it admits the horrors of the war and
the realities of it but it also um
speaks to the
resilience that we live on and that you
know got to just walk around it and go
on keep on
living and that that it's a young
girl felt felt hopeful to
me did you do it by CH you fil by
oh well I mean yeah I mean everything
that's filmed in a documentary is kind
of by chance you know it's just kind of
like oh wait hold on what's Happening
where there's doing okay yeah we go
there yeah all right yeah yeah you know
you're really just flying by the seat of
your pants um that the decision making
really kind of happens in the edit when
you kind of try and make sense of them
and I think if there's any difference
which I don't want to overstate because
I think even in narrative you write in
the edit they're two different languages
you know the na the language of a script
is text and the language of a film
there's no text there's just pictures
and sounds those are two different
languages and you know it's like
translating poetry when you translate
poetry from Arabic to Chinese you're not
going to it's not one to one words you
have to find new poetry in Chinese um so
even when you're cutting
narrative you're
writing but with Doc there is no script
at all so you you you write it all in
the edit um so that's why my first
answer to you was that the
decision to end there happen in the edit
because that's where that's where it
happens okay thank you for coming thank
you so
[Applause]
much